les monuments historiques de la capitale
et de sa proche banlieue n'ont pas été
épargnés c'est le cas du château de
versailles mais aussi du panthéon dont
le dôme a particulièrement souffert des
dégâts également à notre dame ainsi qu'à
la sainte chapelle où un vitrail a été
brisée reportage de nathalie et terre et
laurent soit
à première vue les dégâts ne sont pas
flagrants pourtant il suffit de
s'approcher du dôme du panthéon pour
comprendre que cette tempête la à défaut
de réveiller les morts a bel et bien
arraché une partie du toit de l'édifice
plus d'une dizaine de plaques de plomb
était soufflé est projeté à quelques 80
mètres à la ronde
chacune de ces plaques pèse environ 100
kilos et donc au cours de cette tornade
qui a eu lieu hier matin
dizaines comme celles ci
sont tombés à la fois sur la voie
publique et dans le monument certaines
ont d'ailleurs trans transpercé la
toiture mais d'autres sont roulés un
petit peu comme des feuilles de papier à
cigarette par la force du vent ces
autres plaques devront également être
remplacée coût approximatif des travaux
4 à 5 millions de francs la sainte
chapelle elle a eu de la chance dans son
malheur la chute d'un clocheton a brisé
un vitrail rien de trop important le
monument devrait rouvrir ses portes dans
les prochains jours c'est
incontestablement notre dame qui a le
plus souffert de la tempête au total six
pinacle sont tombés sur la nef et la
sacristie et d'énormes blocs de pierres
ont littéralement troué plusieurs
terrasses catherine trautmann présente
sur les lieux s'est engag eait faciliter
les démarches pour lancer les travaux
d'urgence entre autres dégager les
pierres qui menace à tout moment de
s'effondrer l etat va faire pendant ces
responsables des propriétaires sur mes
propriétaires la cathédrale donc ces
liquides va assurer la remise en l'état
et ensuite la restauration qui
s'imposera en attendant c'est à la
caisse des monuments historiques
d'évaluer le coût des réparations
elles sont actuellement estimés à
quelques 200 millions de francs pour
l'ensemble de la france